[Music]
this episode is sponsored by fabulous
the number one self-care app that helps
you start building better habits
the first hundred people who click on
the link in the description will get 25
off a fabulous subscription
[Laughter]
can you guess what this is
i'll give you a hint
it's extinct
and it's something that we probably
would never have expected to be filming
for our channel which i suppose you
could say is sort of the theme of
today's episode
things we never thought we'd be showing
you but here we are and we're going to
return to this and talk about what it is
but we've got a lot of unseen worlds to
get to first
[Music]
a while ago james our master of
microscopes received a package from a
coral farm containing a number of
exciting things for him to study under
the microscope including a beautiful
brick that had been harboring all sorts
of life
we've done a few episodes on what he
found but of course there's always more
so james decided to keep the brick in a
saltwater tank so that he could see what
else might show up
and one day he found what seemed like an
array of tiny two-headed vases growing
on the surface of the brick
these are tunicates
though they're better known by their
very adorable name sea squirts
they get their name because they can
squirt water out of their bodies when
something touches them or when they're
taken out of water
unfortunately it turned out that
collecting and filming sea squirts was a
bit of a challenge
they're big and fragile which isn't a
good combination when you're trying to
put something under the microscope but
the parts that james was able to observe
were still fascinating to watch
this is the end of one of those tubes
which are called siphons coming off the
sea squirt and inside are several algae
living in symbiosis with their sea
squirt home
the sea squirt has two siphons for a
very simple reason
one is to take things in and one is to
take things out
one siphon draws water into the sea
squirt allowing it to pass through the
organism so that it can eat the little
bits of plankton and other food
traveling on that internal wave and then
once the sea squirt is done with the
water it passes it back out through the
other siphon
[Music]
unlike the sea squirt it was pretty easy
for us to record this ciliate under the
microscope
and there's probably nothing shocking
about our channel showcasing a ciliate
but we'll get there
the ciliate is called
lipidotracholophylum
which is honestly a mouthful even by
silly at name standards and if you look
around the organism you can see a fuzzy
halo
we can't see what that halo is with our
microscope but james's mentor professor
genoveva
has a scanning electron microscope
that's able to peer into that halo and
with it we can see thousands of tiny
organic scales layering that fuzz
james usually finds these ciliates in a
pond next to his house
so again it's not really a surprise to
see it show up here but this
this is more surprising
this is a lepidotreculophile
but unlike the previous ones we were
watching which have just one mouth at
the tip extending and seeking food
this one has two mouths
one in each of those finger finger-like
projections at the top of your screen
james asked professor esteban about this
ciliate because she's seen countless
ciliates over the course of her own
microcosmos journey
some of which she even drew for our
micro cosmos poster that is available
over at microcosmos.store
she told james that yes among her many
strange sightings she'd actually once
come across a sample filled with
hundreds and hundreds of two-headed
ciliates like this
though they were a different species
called euronema so maybe one day we'll
find more of these two-headed
lepidotrecolophylum and this will seem
less shocking to us
but for now well
it is still a strange sight
and speaking of sight
this is an eye
that is not our smoothest transition but
in our defense it's hard to switch gears
from a two-headed ciliate to this
a fish
when james ventures out to waters he
brings a net with him
the goal is to gather ciliates but you
can't just stop other creatures from
entering the plankton net if that's
where they swim
so that means sometimes our master of
microscopes becomes an accidental
fisherman
thick theology is not our strong suit so
we're not sure what kind of fish this is
but if any of you know feel free to tell
us in the comments
[Music]
part of what we found fascinating is
just how iridescent its eyes are under
the desk lamp that james uses to light
up more opaque creatures like this one
unfortunately the journey from water to
microscope
isn't great for fish it's difficult to
extricate them from the nets and it's
also challenging to get the
environmental conditions of their new
home just right
after putting this fish back in its jar
james returned the next day and sadly
found that it had died
but he decided to keep watching the
fish's eye
because as grim as it is
we have to admit that it's beautiful in
its iridescence
eyes are complicated biological devices
having to transmit light that creates a
usable image for us to process
that means filtering out light that's
unfocused and that might interfere with
the final image
humans and plenty of other animals rely
on melanin pigments in our eyes to
absorb those unfocused bits of light but
fish eyes are iridescent because they
work differently for mars
when researchers studied zebrafish eyes
they found that the iris has a layer of
guanine crystals that reflect light back
instead of absorbing it
that reflective action creates the
iridescent sheen while simultaneously
bouncing the light in a way that makes
the fish less conspicuous in its
environment
and that brings us back to the beginning
to our weird extinct sample
james has gotten plenty of strange
things delivered to his house in the
name of microscopy but this is probably
one of the strangest so far
the sample came from a bag of mammoth
hair that he got from siberia
how did james come by the opportunity to
receive a bag of mammoth hair
according to him
he knows a guy who knows a guy but
apparently it's also not that hard to
find mammoth hair on the internet
a quick search on ebay pulls up many
listings of mammoth hair
though we're not quite sure how
believable their claims of authenticity
are
the availability of this hair may be
exciting but it's also the result of a
warming climate which is melting
permafrost across siberia and revealing
the ancient life that once called the
area home
there's
something in all of this about the fact
that shifts in climate which likely
contributed to the extinction of woolly
mammoths are now revealing their remains
but james wasn't examining their hair to
resolve questions of extinction or
explore possibilities of resurrection
he was hoping to find some ciliate
buried in the sample
perhaps wrapped up in a cyst that might
have protected it and kept it fused to a
strand of a woolly mammoth's hair
unfortunately
he couldn't find one of those ciliates
but the search continues
because if he does find one then james
will have found a ciliate that might
have existed when the woolly mammoth
itself was wandering the earth an
ancient unseen world
unburied and revealed in a tangle of
hair
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to fabulous for sponsoring
this episode fabulous is an app that was
created by behavioral science
researchers to gently support your
personal goals habit changing and habit
building is hard so if you're looking
for ways to add a new thing to your
routine fabulous is the way to go
it makes it easy to set new goals and
track your progress as you reach your
well-being goals you can choose a
self-guided style where you track any of
your habits or a guided approach by
selecting one of their dedicated
programs to support your wellness goals
you'll get personalized reminders
motivating lessons to keep you going and
access to a full library of exercises to
support your journey with over 30
million users fabulous can help you
whether you're looking for ways to stay
focused at work or if you're looking to
develop a whole new morning routine the
app is a hundred percent personalized to
your goals and with their daily coaching
and goal setting you can start building
your ideal daily routine today
the first hundred people who click on
the link in the description will get 25
off a fabulous subscription
[Music]
we'd also like to thank all of the
people whose names are on the screen
right now
these are some of our patreon patrons
who decided that they would like to give
us some money every month to help this
channel exist
so thank you again to all of them and
all of you for watching and supporting
this channel
if you'd like to join our patreon
community you can do so over at
patreon.com
journey to micro
if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes james weiss you
can check out jam and germs on instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you